the Joe Rogan experience comedians have
come on and talked about it is it is it
just i'm obviously asking you because I
make nuran is is DMT isn't that the
chemical your body releases as you died
I think your body releases as you died
but they don't really know they know
that your body makes it mmm they know
that your liver makes in your lungs make
it and they think that your pine eel
gland makes it which is your third eye
like and reptiles it actually has a
retina and a lens really yeah yeah the
pineal gland it sits in the center of
your brain literally is your third eye
like if you look at like a third eye and
the Eastern mysticism that's where the
pineal gland is and now they know that
rats while they're alive produce DMT in
the pineal gland this is a new study
that was done I think this research was
published over the last five or six
years so because of the fact they know
that now they're assuming that human
beings also produce it in the pineal
gland which would you know it kind of
sort of verifies what everybody always
thought the pineal gland is they thought
they would call it the seed of the soul
that this is where your your journey to
the afterlife begins in the pineal gland
and that this chemical gateway opens up
and your soul passes through to the
great beyond but it can it be like a bad
trip on the way ass oh yes I've met I've
been with people who had bad DMT trips I
was at Stanhope I got Stanhope high on
DMT and I thought he was dying he said
is that my house he's moaning and
foaming at the mouth
I'd never seen anybody do that before
I'd see a bunch of people most people
smoked DMT they do this they smoked it
and then they just go when they lay back
and then this this overwhelming
experience happens to them for like 15
minutes and then they come that's it and
they come back yeah they don't move they
just it's not ours
no no no it's a quick experience
ayahuasca is an orally active experience
with DMT what ayahuasca is when you if
you tried to eat DMT DMT is broken down
in your gut by something called
monoamine oxidase so when they make
ayahuasca what they do is they take
one plant which has dimethyltryptamine
and part of another plant which has
something called harmine which is a DM
it's a mono a mean oxidase inhibitor mao
inhibitors there's some and medications
and there's some is a bunch of like you
had to be very careful if you're taking
mushrooms or something else that you not
taking mao inhibitors as well but so you
take this stuff together and when it
does is gives you an orally active DMT
trip so as it's broken down by your gut
it's like a slow release DMT trip
that'll take several hours as opposed to
this [ __ ] rocket ship right to the
center of the universe that you get when
you take it when you smoke it because
when you smoke it or intravenous use if
you you know go to a doctor and it's
going to do that that goes directly in
your bloodstream and it's just so it is
impossible to avoid you cannot you can't
hang on you're just it's gonna take you
to the center of the [ __ ] universe
and you're gonna experience life forms
and interaction with spirits and angels
and aliens and gestures for me as a
bunch of gestures that would give me the
finger
it was great giving me the finger like
[ __ ] you like it was very very very very
powerful but did stanhope one was the
only time I ever saw someone or I
thought they were gonna die and I'll
stay I can't what if I kill one of my
best friends like what if I killed
Stanhope I yeah you know I was like I
don't remember I think I did it first
because I think he hadn't done it before
so I said I'll do it just watch me do it
and just sit down here and then you do
it next so I did it I'm gone
fifteen minutes come back Mike you ready
he's like yeah I'm horribly so I give it
to him and you know Stanhope's been
drinking since he was three his his
body's mostly held together with duct
tape
you know lies down if he lies down and
pushes his stomach out he's got these
he's got these [ __ ] what is it called
ham no not hemorrhoids was it called
hernias
he's got hernias his stomach will poke
through the wall the stomach or is a his
gut will pop this aligns all of his
abdomen he's got a bunch of those got
them all over the place just like this
he'll pop up like you're supposed to get
those yes
he just just keeps on trucking
he's and I've talked to him about this -
he's like one of those no MRI guys nah
no doctors no MRIs and I got I don't
want to know what's going on in there
that's everyone dead in my family by the
way that's why I go to dr. everybody so
and this was more than ten years ago
this is probably 2002 well this is all
going down
so me and Stanhope are on my couch and
he is moaning like this foams coming out
of the corner of his mouth and he's
slumped over and I'm just praying - I'm
like please don't die please don't
because I didn't expect this I expected
what everybody else who I've seen maybe
a handful of people do DMT they all do
the same thing they smoke it they lay
back they trip balls they come back in
15 minutes and they're like what the
[ __ ] was that about but he was moment he
came back is like oh life eats life
there's a constant cycle it's like it
just goes on and to the next thing and
then life goes on and life is like yes
I'm so far behind and so far Bahamas my
thinking I'm so far behind with
everything and I'm just like I'm just
glad you're alive dude yeah no [ __ ]
you
[Applause]